[Musique]
quelques pas de danse presque joyeux en
apparence car les salariés de mbf était
loin d'avoir le sourire ce mardi à
sochaux
ils étaient près de 150 mobilisés devant
l' usine du groupe sts elantis clients
historiques du sous-traitant jurassien
qui lutte toujours pour sa survie
psa est le principal acteur en tout cas
pour la fonderie d'un bep effect qui qui
représente à peu près 75 % du chiffre
d'affaires c'est important parce que
c'est quand même les constructeurs
français qui font la pluie et le beau
temps et c'est leur stratégie en tout
cas si qui met à mal toute une filière
fonderie en france et plus précisément
la nôtre aussi pour la fonderie mbf les
prochaines semaines seront cruciales
l'entreprise du haut jura est en
redressement judiciaire depuis le mois
de novembre
280 postes sont toujours menacés et les
salariés se disent inquiets physiquement
moralement elle c'est très très présent
vraiment vous faites au quotidien pour
avoir cette lueur d'espoir est restée
mobilisée au prix en espèces là on a un
atelier qui était unique en france une
fonderie qui est unique en france
il est important de défendre cet atelier
là il important de donner ce message là
aux grands donneurs d'ordre que sont psa
elle et les grosses les gros les gros
groupes installés en font un marché
automobile tourner vers l'hybride et des
commandes de pièces en chute libre
c'est la crainte des syndicats de mbf
qui dénonce un désengagement de la part
des constructeurs français
c'est pas énorme ils peuvent se le
permettre au lieu d'envoyer en espagne
en chine où n'importe quel pays low cost
faudrait qu'ils rapatrient ça ici je
rappelle quand même que psa à cinq
moteurs hybrides fait en espagne alors
qu'il pourrait en donner deux ou trois
en france on s'en sortirait tout alors
après cette première mobilisation ici à
sochaux les salariés de mbf ont prévu
d'aller manifester devant le siège
social de renault ce jeudi à paris autre
date importante celle du 27 avril
si d'ici là mbf aluminium n'a pas trouvé
de repreneur
le tribunal de dijon pourrait prononcer
une situation de liquidation judiciaire
pour l'entreprise du haut jura